welcome to cbs this morning dr fauci is
right the number really is staggering
it's hard to think that it could get
worse but it could but it's not over
we are living through a very dark
chapter in american history and that's
actually where we're going to begin that
staggering milestone in the coronavirus
pandemic a toll unthinkable a year ago
the number of lives lost from cobia 19
will soon reach half a million today
with the real number likely higher than
that
we're talking about roughly one in every
670 americans
think about this 300 000 people died in
the u.s in the first 10 months of the
pandemic
and nearly 200 000 more have died just
since mid
december every one of those deaths is a
person who was alive
a year ago and the grief felt by their
families cannot be adequately measured
by any number
but there is also a reason for hope this
morning as we fight this pandemic
together
with new cases and new hospitalizations
continuing to drop
let's go now to our lead national
correspondent david begno in los angeles
county which has had more cases than any
other county in america
but where compassion has helped ease the
suffering
david good morning to you good way to
put it good morning to you listen we're
at the coroner's office because we were
surprised to confirm yesterday
they're still holding 1100 bodies here
for hospitals around l.a county
that have run out of work space because
the pandemic has simply stretched
resources they're still dealing with
that today
i want you to hear from a man who runs a
funeral home here in l.a county he is
often
the final phone call a lot of families
in this pandemic have to make
it's grown to the point that we actually
have to give a reservation code
to a family just so that they could be
seen meet ken mckenzie the four
churches as well are so backlogged when
people call him he says they usually
want to interview him
to decide if they want to use his
services but now
the first question is are you taking
cases
the panic in their voice is just so sad
mckenzie runs his own funeral home here
in long beach california
he says even with cases declining he is
busier now than at
any other point in the pandemic a year
ago
people were complaining about not
finding toilet paper
and his hand sanitizers this time of
year
we're concerned because we're running
out of granite for headstones
she gave covet to her sister another
sister died
and we're mimicking the same funeral
i've been doing this since i was 19
years old
those words that come so easily i
struggle with lately
among the nearly 500 000 people who have
died with covet 19
these are just some of the faces of the
people mckenzie and his team have cared
for
in death including
three members of the rangel family who
mckenzie cremated
in a span of 16 days all three of them
passed due to covet luis
jerry and alma rangel my sister was
alone we had to watch her on an ipad
take her last breath i had to ask a
doctor that i didn't know
to hold her hand for me because i
couldn't be there for her
it was the wrangle family walking into
his funeral home with back to back
deaths
that just broke him i have never broke
down i'm supposed to be the professional
and it was yet another death with the
same family
and i sat there and cried with them what
was it
that made you break down it's just
hopeless it's
like unreal
i gotta say listening to you is such a
reality check
but i'm just waiting for the trolls who
will watch this and say
it's nothing but fear-mongering when you
say trolls
i like that you said that because that's
to me someone that just is not informed
it's under a bridge that's hiding that
doesn't want to face the truth
i'm hoping these words today hit home to
those people
tonight at sunset president biden is
planning to make remarks at a
candlelight vigil honoring the nearly
500 thousand people killed mr biden will
be joined
by the first lady the vice president and
the second gentleman
i'm glad they're doing that david you
know you've been covering the story from
the very beginning you've seen a lot of
laws covering this story
and you've shared those stories with us
some of them have been heartbreaking on
the other hand
some of them have also been very
uplifting too but i can't stop thinking
about this number
behind this number these are people
these are families
these are people who are dearly loved so
what stands out to you as you look back
on this
really less than a year we're reaching
this milestone
uh gail i have to be honest with you the
first thing that comes to mind is a
story we haven't told it might be the
one story we haven't told and it
is the disrespect that has been done by
the trolls on social media which have
for the last year
sowed doubt mistrusts and really
poisoned the public health here and and
politicians really are to blame in many
respects right
there are people who were looking for
good guidance
but every time you post one of these
stories there's just this
incredible amount of misinformation that
is spread by people who are either
looking to cause trouble
or afraid and it's not only done a
disservice to trying to keep people on
the same page
it's been disrespectful to the memories
of the nearly 500
000 people that's one of the things that
i reflect on such a good point i love
the man in your story who just said you
know a year ago we were fighting about
toilet paper and hand sanitizers
now we're talking about tombstones i
can't that will stick with me
so where are we now where are we going
from here do you think
look the light at the end of the tunnel
i keep hearing every day when i
interview a doctor is the vaccines
bottom line
president biden says by july everyone
who wants a vaccine
should be able to get one we talk a lot
about those variants gail here's the
good news it appears as though pfizer
and moderna's vaccine
is effective against the uk variant it's
only about 50
effective against the south african
variant remember the good news about the
variants is even though they're more
contagious
they're not believed to be more deadly
so there is a light at the end of the
tunnel but the bottom line
masks social distancing i know it seems
trite and cliche
it saves lives trust us
i do trust you and you can't say it
enough thank you very much david begne